The right answer is exokernel. Now so long as SPIN's logical
protection remains, are entirely following modular
three language enforced, compile time checking, and run time
verification, there is no violation of protection In SPIN. But
we cannot say the same about Exokernel because it is arbitrary code
that is being downloaded into the kernel
by a library operating system and that's
the reason that Exokernel may end up
compromising protection more than the SPIN mechanism.
But having said that, I should mention that it's not always possible to live
within modular three enforced protection domains, even
in SPIN. Because we've seen that even
in SPIN, in order to do certain things in the hardware, SPIN
may have to step outside the protection boundaries of
modular three. In other words, a reality that exists with
real hardware is that it's not always possible to do this within the
confines of language-enforced protection domains.
But if you just think in terms of the
logical protection domains as defined by SPIN as modular
three objects. Those have strong guarantees of protection compared
to arbitrary code that we can download into Exokernel.